yeah I'm surprised he wasn't able to sit
down with like the daily wire crew
apparently that's not going to happen
Okay so they didn't want him on on he
said that on the Lex Freeman interview
he said it and Alexa's like wait they
didn't want you on and he was like yes
they said they didn't want me on that's
crazy I mean I get it you have to
imagine Ben Shapiro's like dude not cool
I mean it's like you know Ben's Jewish
but I do think communication is the
solution I I have I mean unless you're
gonna try and denial I want to see a
Kanye Ben Shapiro debate it would be
entertaining it would be yeah crazy but
it would be a clash of different ideas
and as you mentioned Tim you know a lot
of people have those kind of different
ideas but but at the same time what
better way to deal with it what better
way to to get rid of a lot of this
animosity a lot of this hatred than to
be able to just to talk things out and
be able to of course pin ideas against
ideas let the best ideas win